hallo und herzlich willkommen zur
heute-show unnatürlich zur verleihung
des goldenen vollpfosten 2019 so sie
können sich denken wir müssen aus
aktuellem anlass direkt mit boris
johnson loslegen mit mister let's get
brachse dann ist ja klar was für eine
unglaublich spannende war gestern in
großbritannien kommen gegen johnson ihre
oder hätten sie gedacht dass es so
aussehen auf der insel
meine fresse das war vielleicht dass
diese verrückten briten wirklich also
die heute show wurde bereits gestern am
frühen abend aufgezeichnet daher
versucht oliver welke plump zu
überspielen dass er keine ahnung hat wie
die wahl ausgegangen ist wir bitten um
entschuldigung
glücklich
da die bombe
anyway als kontinentaleuropäer kann man
ja eh nicht fassen dass jemand wie john
sie mir überhaupt so weit kommen konnte
der mann hat überlegen sie mal sein
komplettes berufsleben durch gelogen aus
stück ein journalist und politiker dafür
ist er wie wir gelernt haben ein
ausgezeichneter komiker hier eine
ehrliche publikumsreaktion masse der
traut sich was oder ja seine tories
haben seit 2010 die sozialausgaben
massiv gekürzt ganz klar einer der
gründe für die politische krise im land
statt sich das mal einzugestehen macht
unser boris weiter unhaltbare
versprechungen hier im sunday times
interview sagt er
der brh exit wird einen baby boom
auslösen na klar man kann schon sein
dass da demnächst mehr babys kommen denn
mit ihrem wechsel sind die briten ja
offiziell geschickt ich persönlich hatte
immer auf ein zweites referendum gehofft
aber ob das was bringen würde und nicht
alles stimmen überein manche wollen dem
rexit manchen ist es war ein split 50
heftige eigentliche und sagt wenn er
noch mal ein ware geben würde dann wird
es 50 15 der andere richtung gehen
ist gut möglich man weiß es nicht bei
bei briten
man möchte auf kölsch noch hinterher
rufen niemals geht man so ganz
beziehungsweise never goes waren zur
komplett liegt und das ist tatsächlich
wörtlich zu nehmen denn selbst wenn die
briten am 31 januar wie geplant gehen
sollten bleiben danach nur elf monate
zeit um ein freihandelsabkommen mit der
eu hinzukriegen
nur zum vergleich am abkommen mit den
mercosur staaten in südamerika wurde
tatsächlich 20 jahre lang verhandelt
elf monate keine chance mit anderen
worten traut aber weiter präsentiert
rexit für kleine dose engländer die den
ausgang nicht finden
das erste brettspiel der welt das
garantiert nirgendwo hinführt es sei für
oder gegen dem exit völlig egal denn
alle figuren laufen eh nur sinnlos im
kreis vorsicht dass briggs it felt sie
schnell eine ereignis verhinderungs
karte zwischen 5 stunden und dreißig
jahre die chance
noch weniger spaß geht echt nicht
wechselt das spiel ohne praxis
[Applaus]
ich sage mal wie's kommt unsere eu kommt
auch sehr gut ohne briten klar jetzt wie
von der leyen chefin ist neuer eu
wirtschaftskommissar und damit für
stabilität zuständig ist ab sofort kein
witz ein italiener
was soll da noch schiefgehen wir
verleihen unseren ersten goldenen
vollpfosten einmal mehr an
großbritannien denn die sehnsucht nach
identität schlägt offensichtlich
vernunft und fakten die brits gutes
europäisches essen werdet ihr euch bald
nicht mehr leisten können deswegen
glückwunsch zum fish and chips posten
oben mit echter remoulade hallo leute
ich bin's der heute-show hersteller
wenn ihr mehr heißen scheiß und limes
wollt dann abonniert jetzt den kanal
was zur hölle ist minimal hersteller